nir santé les antennes relais des
téléphones mobiles sont elles
dangereuses
une association avait relevé que les
quatre cancers et est deux fois et demie
supérieur à la moyenne dans un quartier
de saint cyr l'école où l'une de ses
antennes avait été installée et bien les
autorités sanitaires viennent de rendre
leur conclusion il n'y a aucun lien
distel laurence de cher vincent ferreira
ils l'attendaient depuis deux ans les
habitants de sentir l'école viennent
d'avoir la conclusion de l'enquète
sanitaires sur les cons ce cas de
cancers d'enfants en 13 ans en 2003 ils
ont obtenu le démontage des antennes de
téléphonie mobile placée sur le toit de
cette école aujourd'hui les résultats
confirment leurs doutes il ya ici deux
fois plus de cancers chez l'enfant
qu'ailleurs et quatre fois plus de
cancers du système nerveux central
mais ce nombre élevé reste un mystère
concluant à l'absence de sources
environnementale identifiables qui
puisse expliquer la survenue de ces 11
cas une enquête incomplète pour les
parents d'élèves le lien entre maladie
et antennes de téléphonie mobile ayant
d'emblée été écartée ça me révolte
je suis frustré trois ans pourra vivre
pour aboutir à le hasard savait comment
voulez vous qu'on s'en sorte
bon bah moi je vais expliquer aux
familles c'est le hasard qui ont fait
leurs enfants aucune personne malade n'a
été interrogé
donc il me semble que quand même c'était
la moindre des choses d'aller voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'humain est ce que c'est ça qu'il
s'agisse et c'est du concret pas
question d'en rester là les associations
et les parents d'élèves réclament la
poursuite des investigations